DOMINIC PREUSS: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Dominic
Preuss, and I'm
very excited to be here
at Google I/O. So welcome
to everyone who made it this far
in the conference and everyone
that's on the Livestream.
First of all, you made it to the
last session of the last day.
So round of applause to
everyone who's still here.
[APPLAUSE]
We're very excited to
talk about Cloud Spanner.
Before we get started, I want
to set your expectations.
So before we do the
session, I want to tell you
what we're going to do.
And if there are other
sessions you want to go to,
I won't be offended, but I want
you to know what to expect.
So in this session, we're going
to talk about a brief history
of Spanner at Google.
I'm going to give you
an explanation of what
Cloud Spanner is, and
then we'll do a demo.
And hopefully we'll have a
few minutes left at the end
to do some question and answer.
So why did we build
Cloud Spanner?
So you have to go back to 2005.
Every dollar that Google made
in its advertising system
called AdWords was built
on the back of a manually
sharded MySQL cluster.
We were sharding
by customer IDs,
and we had to move a customer.
They had outgrown the
shard, and we needed
to move them to another shard.
That last re-shard took
multiple years to complete.
And when we did that, we decided
we had to have a better way.
How many people in the room have
either a manually sharded MySQL
or a manually sharded
Postgres implementation?
All right, so those
of you in the room
know the pain that we felt.
So it was at that point
that we decided we need
to do something different.
So what were Google's needs?
We needed a horizontally
scaling database
that we could give our most
mission critical data to.
So we needed ACID transactions
with global consistency.
AdWords was already a global
product at that point,
and we needed no downtime.
Every minute that
we were down cost us
millions of dollars of revenue.
So how were we going
to solve this problem?
So the answer was Spanner.
So what is Cloud Spanner?
We're going to start by taking
you through a quick video
as an overview of
what the product is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We demand a lot
of our databases,
and our databases
demand a lot of us.
They're fragile, expensive,
and tough to maintain.
When things break, it can be
hard to put the pieces back
together at the speed
of your business,
and you often lose
data in the process.
We've all come to expect the
distributed databases can't
be globally consistent
and scalable.
But what if you didn't
have to make tradeoffs?
What if you could have a
fully managed database service
that's consistent,
scales horizontally
across data centers,
and speaks SQL?
This is Cloud Spanner, a mission
critical relational database
service built from the
ground up and battle
tested at Google for
strong consistency
and high availability
at global scale.
At Google, we use
Spanner for services
that billions of people
access every day.
It's the only cloud
service designed
to be a massively
distributed relational
database with transactions
and SQL semantics.
And we're talking massive.
Spanner can scale up to millions
of machines across hundreds
of data centers and trillions
of database rows stretched
across the globe while
behaving like it's all in one
place, where you want it.
We built Cloud Spanner to
be fully managed and secure.
Automatic sharding and
synchronous replication
with low latency and schema
updates without downtime
means your data is highly
available and reliable.
Instead of endless provisioning
and worrying about maintenance,
you can focus on
growing your business.
No matter your
needs, you don't have
to hit a wall with
your database service.
Get started with Cloud
Spanner, and build what's next.
[END PLAYBACK]
DOMINIC PREUSS: So Cloud
Spanner is the externalization
of that technology that we
started building in 2005.
So in 2005 we started
building Spanner.
It went into production to
power the AdWord system in 2007.
And over the last
nine-plus years,
many of Google's mission
critical applications
run on Spanner.
Cloud Spanner is the Google
Cloud Platform service
that we have exposed to give
outside developers access
to the same powerful
tools that we
have inside of Google for their
mission critical applications.
So Cloud Spanner is a fully
managed database service
with global scale.
So what this means is you come
in, you create an instance,
you put data in the system,
and that's all you worry about.
We do backups, we do
upgrades, security patches,
and making sure that your data
is always protected and secure.
The second thing was it's
a traditional relational
database.
So it gives you
relational semantics,
so you have rows and
tables and schemas,
as well as the
transactional capabilities.
You have ACID transactions
across as many rows
as you want.
You can update
hundreds or millions
of rows in a single transaction,
and you get to use SQL.
So we do all of our
SQL definition in SQL,
and we do all of
our queries in SQL.
It's ANSI 2011 SQL
extensions, so it's
been built to be
as compatible as it
can be with your existing
relational database
technologies.
We do automatic
synchronous replication
within and across
regions for availability.
So one of the things
that is inherently
different about
Google Cloud Platform
versus other public clouds is
that we work off the assumption
that we have to be
multi-regional to reach
the level of availability
necessary to run our business.
So Google Cloud Storage is
inherently multi-regional,
Cloud Datastore
is multi-regional,
and Cloud Spanner is designed
to run multi-regional.
It's also been battle
tested inside of Google.
So we say here five years
for things like AdWords
in the Google PlayStore, but
it's been now over nine years
that we've been building
applications and running
all of Google's mission critical
applications on Spanner.
So the question is, so what?
You've said a bunch
of words, you've
said a bunch of database terms.
What does that actually mean?
So what Cloud Spanner
allows you to do
is have the horizontal
scalability of a NoSQL Solution
with the relational and
transactional characteristics
of a relational database.
So what this means is, when
you come across a problem--
a business problem that requires
a solution, you have an answer.
We see this pattern
time and time
again with both our large
enterprise customers
and our cloud native
companies where
they build a project
or a solution
or a technology on top of
the database that they know.
It might be MySQL, it might
be Postgres, SQL Server,
or whatever it happens to be.
And then if that project
becomes very successful,
if it gets popular and they
have scalability issues.
So now they have to
worry about things
like read replicas to
scale reads and continue
to scale out their solution.
And at some point they basically
outgrow that technology.
So if you've outgrown your
relational database technology,
your one immutable requirement
is horizontal scalability.
So then this takes you into
things like Cassandra and MySQL
and those eventually consistent
technologies that give you
the horizontal
scalability, but then you
have to re-architect your
application to understand
those consistency requirements.
Cloud Spanner allows you to
scale out your application
without compromises around
transactional semantics
or your relational structures.
So if you compare this to
a traditional relational
database, Cloud SQL has schemas,
SQL, strong consistency.
We don't have failover because
we don't do master-slave.
We use a custom paxos consensus
algorithm and two-face
commits so that we
don't have master-slave.
We have consistent versions of
the data in all the replicas,
so we can serve your
data out of whichever
replica is most expedient.
Instead of vertical scaling
by creating bigger VMs where
you're limited to the
largest VM that you
can get from a public
cloud provider,
we scale horizontally.
And then also replication--
it's not configurable.
It's something you
get automatically.
Now, how does this compare
to your NoSQL Solutions?
So NoSQL Solutions,
no schemas, limited
SQL or NoSQL,
eventual consistency,
you can get high
availability because you
have a distributed
system because you
can scale horizontally.
But you still have to
worry about configuring
your replication.
So Spanner allows you to
have the best of both worlds
in a single solution.
One of the biggest
questions that I get
is you've had Spanner
internally for nine years.
Why was it so hard to bring
it to the outside world?
We worked on it for years,
and it was in early access
for over a year.
And it's because
we really wanted
to package Spanner in such a
way that it was open standards
and it met our enterprise
customers where they are.
Google is tremendously
committed to the idea
being the open cloud.
So we wanted to adopt
any open standards
that we could to
really make sure
that it was as easy as possible
to adopt this technology.
So we used standard SQL, which
is ANSI 2011 with extensions.
We do extensions for things
like interleaved tables
and some of the things that
are specific to Spanner.
For our enterprise
customers, out of the box
you get encryption at
rest, you get audit logging
so you can know who's making
changes to your database,
and integration with Google
Cloud Platform's identity
and access management.
So you get rule-based access
patterns to all of your data.
So if you're a large
enterprise company that's
trying to move your mission
critical data on to Google
Cloud Platform
and Cloud Spanner,
these are things that you need
to know that you've achieved
the solution that you need.
We've also got open
source client libraries
for all the popular languages.
We talk a lot about being a
developer from the platform,
and for us that means really
strong documentation and really
great client libraries.
So we launched our beta with
Java, Python, Go, and Node.
And just today we
launched our PHP clients,
and we've got Ruby and C#
client libraries coming shortly.
The last thing we did was
we've developed a JDBC driver.
So we have a read only
JDBC driver specifically
for our partner ecosystem.
So partners are tremendously
important to Google's success
for the Google Cloud Platform.
So by providing
this JDBC driver,
we made as easy as possible
for both our partners,
like Tableau and Looker and
MicroStrategy, the BI tools,
as well as customers
to integrate it
into their workloads.
So we provide this
read-only JDBC driver
to make it easy as possible to
get the data out of the system.
During the early
access program and now
from beta to general
availability,
we've seen a lot of traction
on specific types of workloads,
and these workloads are
actually very similar to what
we've seen inside Google.
So the first one
is transactional.
If you have a heavily
transactional workload where
you need global
consistency, Cloud Spanner
is an ideal solution.
So examples of this
are financial services.
If you're moving
around money, you
need to have consistent data.
If you are doing inventory
management or supply chain
applications, you can't sell
more inventory than you have.
So it's important that you
have a strongly consistent data
store to store your inventory.
Another good example
of this is Adtech.
So Adtech, money,
budgets, you're
serving ads against
the budget, you
can't spend more than the
budget of the customer.
So it's very important that
you have a consistent database
for those types of systems.
The next one is scale out,
and so the type of customer
that we actually--
is the easiest to
understand Cloud Spanner
are those that have these
manually sharded MySQL
and Postgres databases.
If your database has gotten
large enough that you
are manually sharding
your database,
either at the application
layer, using some sort
of sharding technology,
then you understand the need
for having a horizontally
scalable database.
The fact that you can
pick a single database
and never have to worry
about outgrowing it up
to petabytes of
data is something
that's very
reassuring when you're
choosing an architectural
solution to build
your applications on.
The third one is
global data plane.
So an interesting fact is
that Google Cloud Platforms--
all of its control planes
are based on Spanner.
And so if you have to have a
consistent view of your systems
for control plane or
things like user accounts,
we see this as a really common
use case for Cloud Spanner.
If your customers happen
to be globally distributed,
let's say that you're
a US company that
has a lot of customers in Japan
or a European company that
has a lot of
customers in the US,
then having a
globally distributed
single source of truth system
for things like user accounts
and metadata on your
system is very valuable.
The last one is consolidation,
and this is actually one
that I'm most excited about.
As a former CTO of a company,
we had multiple solutions.
We had a Postgres database
for our customer data.
We had a Mongo database
for our logging data,
and we had a analytics solution
for all of our logging data.
And so what's great
about Cloud Spanner
is it allows you to
consolidate all your data
stores into a single one.
So if you had a Postgres
cluster for your user data
and a Cassandra cluster for
all of your logging data,
you can now bring those
into a single, scalable data
source that is globally
consistent with a single source
of truth to run
your applications.
And this really starts to
give you much greater velocity
from a developer perspective.
You don't have to worry
about e-tailing the data
or trying to do joins
across disparate data sets.
You have a single source
for all of your data.
So you can do real time,
consistent queries on the data.
So how does Spanner work?
So the atomic unit for Cloud
Spanner is an instance.
So when you create a
Cloud Spanner instance,
you're selecting two things--
a instance configuration,
which is effectively
the replication typology
of the database,
and the number of nodes.
The nodes are the compute
units by which you
can do work on the database.
So once I have that data,
I have created my instance.
If you're creating a regional
instance which we have today
and we'll have multi-regional
instances rolling out later
this year--
for a regional
instance, you're going
to have three replicas
in three different zones
in a single region.
And then when you create
a database inside of that
instance-- so your database
is your logical separation
of your data--
all of that data is
going to be available
and copied and replicated across
all of your various replicas.
So what this does is gives
you a fault tolerant,
highly available system
that has your data separated
across multiple zones.
So what happens is when a
update comes into the system,
you don't address
a single replica.
You don't address a cluster.
You just address your instance.
So whether or not you're doing
a write from a virtual machine
in Europe or the United
States, you just say,
hey, Cloud Spanner,
here's some data.
We will automatically
route that data
to the nearest replica that
can serve your request.
It'll come into one
of the replicas.
The commit will be figured
out using our paxos algorithm
and our two-faced
commits, and then we'll
get consensus from the other
replicas to write that data.
All of that is completely
transparent to you.
And when you're writing
data to Cloud Spanner,
it looks just like a
single node database.
There's nothing
about the behavior
that you will see that will look
any different than if you are
addressing an
individual, single node
database like MySQL or Postgres.
In terms of what this
does in terms of latency
is when you're
doing reads, you're
talking about single
millisecond reads,
and you're talking about
sub 15 millisecond writes.
So depending on the
shape of your data
and how fast you're writing
data and reading data,
you're going to see very similar
performance that you would
see out of a single
node machine,
but you're getting
the distributed
nature of Cloud Spanner.
Well, how does
Spanner achieve this?
There has to be some tradeoffs.
So one of the things
that's really interesting
is how we actually
structure the data.
So if you are using a
traditional database--
traditional relational
database, your data
is going to look like this.
You're going to have a
single table, in this case,
for example, a singer ID.
We've got ID 1, 2,
3, and then we're
going to have an
album table that's
going to have its
own ID, so album ID.
And you might have a
foreign key constraint here,
but you basically have
two disparate tables
and you're doing joins.
Spanner, to be
performant and to support
the relational semantics
in a distributed system,
has the idea of
interleave tables.
So the way that
Spanner does this is we
allow you to tell us what
is the physical relationship
of your data.
An interleaved
table is effectively
a child table that allows you to
create a connection of the data
so that we can
group it together.
You're telling Spanner that
this data, which is albums,
is closely related to singer.
So what that allows us
to do is to make sure
that we keep that data close,
and we can quickly serve data
that is within a single parent.
So in this case, Beatles.
This also is how we implement
foreign key constraints.
So if you want to do things
like cascade on delete,
then you basically have--
all the child table has all
the same keys as the primary,
as its parent, and then you
can say cascade on delete.
So when I delete a
child row, then--
or a parent row, you
can cascade on delete
to make sure that you
maintain that integrity.
We don't do foreign
key constraints
across these top level tables,
which we call root tables,
because then that would
affect our performance.
So by creating this
interleaved table,
we're able to give the
performance that you need,
but structuring the data in
a slightly different way.
So what does that look like
when I build my schemas?
So this is how you do DDL.
So when you define
your schemas, so you
can say create table singers
with singer ID and singer name,
and the primary
key is singer ID.
So we use primary keys
that are actual data.
So we encourage you to create
enough separation in keys
as to use actual data from your
system as the primary keys.
So now if we wanted
to create a child
table or an interleave table, we
would say create table albums.
You can see that it has singer
ID as a key-- as a property
because we need to have all of
the same ones as the parent.
We've added album
ID as a separate ID,
and we've added album name.
So we said the primary keys need
to be singer ID and album ID,
and again, this is so
that we can interleave
the data together, and then
we say interleave and singers.
So what this means is
whenever you create a child
row of the parent
table, that data
will be physically located on
the same nodes in Cloud Spanner
so that we can quickly do
queries across that data.
Some people like to think of
this as a pre-computed join.
So it allows you to basically--
by laying the data on data--
laying the data out on disk and
in the relational semantics,
it allows us to do these
pre-computed joins.
The other thing it allows us to
do is no downtime migrations.
So if you wanted to do,
say, alter table singers
and add column age, that
is a no downtime migration.
So we don't lock the database.
We don't lock the tables.
Spanner does cell level
pessimistic locking,
and so you can do
online schema migrations
without bringing
down your system.
These are all things that
we had to develop to be
able to run Google's business.
It's our mission critical
applications at the scale
and speed that we needed.
So what does this
look like in code?
So I talked a little
bit about the importance
of documentation.
I'll also talk about the
importance of our client
libraries.
I'm a Python guy, so we're
going to go through the Python--
the Python experience.
But we spent a lot of time
with our Google Cloud client
libraries to make sure that it's
as easy as possible to get up
and running.
So for Python-- by the
way, how many Python people
are in the room?
Fantastic.
You're my people.
First thing I'm going
to do is import Spanner
from google.cloud.
So I've imported the package
necessary to get access.
I'm going to
instantiate a client.
So a client is a
pool of connections.
So you create a single
client for your application,
and then the client
libraries in the background
do all the connection pooling
to optimize your network
traffic back and forth.
I'm then going to say, grab
a handle to my instance--
so my instance ID is a string.
I'll pass that to the
client, say grab my instance.
And now I need to
handle the database.
So you could have many
databases per instance.
Again, this is a logical
separation of data.
I'm going to say my database
ID is my database ID,
and then I'm to grab the
handles on my database.
And now I can start
to run queries.
So in seven lines of
code I'm able to start
executing queries, and
then I can start printing
out that data.
As a quick high-level,
how does Cloud Spanner
fit into the overall portfolio?
So if you look at our portfolio
of products going from right
to left, we start with
a in-memory data source
that we provide, Memcache
as part of App Engine.
This is obviously very good
for Web and mobile apps
and for caches.
Cloud SQL is our managed
relational database service.
So today it supports
MySQL and Postgres.
We are very excited to
announce Postgres support
at Cloud Next in March.
Skipping over Cloud
Spanner, Cloud Datastore--
Cloud Datastore is our document
database for mobile and web
applications.
This is what powers things
like Snapchat, Pokemon Go,
and other large
gaming applications.
Cloud Bigtable is our
analytics database.
So this is for high
throughput, low latency write.
So if you need single
millisecond reads and writes
of very large amounts
of data, Cloud Bigtable
is what allows you to do that.
It's fantastic for
time series data,
for monitoring data
or anything that you
need to do those very
heavy writes and then do
really fast tables scans.
Cloud Storage, which
is our object store,
I'd like to keep it
in here because we're
seeing more and more
people that are writing
their data into GCS
or into Google Cloud
Storage as its data store in
things like Avro and Parquet
and JSON files and
log files, and then
running federated queries from
BigQuery across that data.
So we see a number
of people that
are starting to use it
as a column data store
by putting those files directly
into a object store bucket.
And last one is BigQuery, which
is our cloud native warehouse.
So this is a
federated query engine
that allows you to search across
the data in BigQuery, Google
Cloud Storage, Google
Drive, and we recently
announced the ability to query
data in Cloud Bigtable as well.
Fed allows you to do joins
across data in multiple data
sources and doing it all from
a single interface using SQL.
So you come back
to Cloud Spanner.
What is it good for?
So if you are using--
if you have an
application that doesn't
have one of three requirements,
then normally using
MySQL and Postgres is great.
Great ecosystem, lots of tools.
But there are three
things that will drive you
to Cloud Spanner.
If you need super
high availability,
so you either need four
nines of availability
for a regional instance or
five nines of availability
for multi-regional, then Cloud
Spanner is a solution for you.
You don't have to worry
about scheduled downtime
because there isn't any.
We aren't doing-- when
we do binary upgrades,
you don't see it.
It happens online.
It doesn't have any
impact to customers.
Five nines of availability
is 20-some seconds a month
of downtime.
And so it allows you to run your
mission critical applications.
So number one is super
high availability.
Number two is if you
need more writes than you
can put through a single node.
So if you're doing
lots and lots of writes
on your MySQL or
Postgres database,
you can shard the reads
by creating read replicas
and pushing your read
traffic to read replicas.
But if you're doing
more writes than you
can put through
a single VM, then
you can only scale
vertically to as large
as the biggest VM
as on that platform.
So Cloud Spanner allows
you to go beyond that
by doing as many writes as you
want by just adding more nodes.
The last one is data.
So if you have more data
than you can reasonably
put into a relational
database-- and that's
somewhere around
three terabytes--
and you need to be able to
scale up to tens or hundreds
or even petabytes of
data, Cloud Spanner
allows you to scale
beyond the storage
requirements of a traditional
relational database.
So that's where people get
moved from Cloud Spanner into--
or from Cloud SQL
into Cloud Spanner
is when you have one of
those three requirements
that can't be met by a
traditional relational
database.
One note-- when I did
the slide last week,
Cloud Spanner was still in beta.
We actually went to general
availability on Tuesday.
So it is now generally
available for everyone.
It is no longer beta.
You just talked about
a bunch of databases.
Which one do I use when?
So this is something that
I put together recently
that I always like to show in
any database talk is how do I
choose which solution to use.
So we'll start at the top
and work our way down.
So first, is your data
structured, yes or no?
So if the answer
is no, then you're
going to end up over in one of
our unstructured object stores.
So if you need mobile
SDKs, then you're
going to use Firebase Storage.
So for those of
you who don't know,
as you've gotten
through this conference,
Firebase is our mobile
developer platform,
and it's the primary way that
developers-- mobile developers
access Google Cloud
Platform services.
So if you need a mobile SDK,
you'll go to Firebase Storage.
If you don't, then you'll
go to Cloud Storage.
All of the data ends
up in the same place,
but it's just two different
developer experiences.
If your data is
structured, then are you
doing an analytics workload?
If you're doing an
analytics workload,
then you're going end up
over on the right side,
and then your question
is going to be,
do you need lots and lots of
updates or super low latency?
So if the answer is yes, you'll
end up in Cloud Bigtable.
So we recently did an experiment
with a large financial services
company where we're doing
millions and millions of writes
a second into Cloud
Bigtable and we're
talking about sub ten
millisecond reads and writes.
That's Cloud Bigtable.
If you don't need
lots of updates
and you're looking at more
of an append-only workload
or a traditional data
warehouse, then you're
going to end up over in
BigQuery where you're
talking about single
second queries
for doing massive aggregations
over lots and lots of data.
If your data isn't
analytics, then you're
going to end up in
the middle here.
And then the question is,
is your data relational?
Without getting into a
whole religious conversation
about SQL versus NoSQL,
the real question
is, is your data relational?
Do you have lots of references,
and are you doing lots of joins
across multiple tables?
Then this will drive you
into one of two solutions.
So if your data
is not relational,
then the question again is,
do you need mobile SDKs?
If the answer is
no, you're going
to end up in Cloud
Datastore, which
is our scalable document
database for Web
and mobile applications.
If you do want
mobile applications,
you want the native mobile
SDKs, and you're going up
in Firebase real time database.
If your data is
relational, then you're
going to be over on the
left side of our slide.
And so then the
question is, do you
need horizontal scalability?
If you don't, then
generally MySQL and Postgres
are going to provide
you a great experience.
They've got a much more robust
ecosystem, open source tools,
lots of support for you
getting up and running,
and takes away some of
the complexity of doing
the work that you need to do.
But if you do have one of
those three needs, which
is super high
availability, more writes
than you can put through
a single VM, or more data
than you can fit in a
single relational database,
then you're going to
end up in Cloud Spanner.
I talked a little bit
before about how important
it was for Google Cloud
Platform and Cloud Spanner
to have a robust
partner ecosystem.
So we spent a lot of time
during the early access program
and since launch in
engaging with our partners
to make sure that whatever tool
you happen to be using today,
you can continue to
use with Cloud Spanner.
So I'm very excited
that we have support
from companies like Xplenty,
Looker, MicroStrategy,
and we're going to continue
to see integrations roll out
the rest of the year from
Informatica, Tableau,
and all of our various partners.
And so if you happen to
be an Alooma user today
and you want to be able to
migrate your data into Cloud
Spanner, we're
making sure that we
have those integrations in
place for those partners
so that you can use the tools
that you're used to using,
and Cloud Spanner will just
fit right into your existing
architecture.
So now we're going to do a demo.
So before you switch
over to the machine,
any good talk has a demo.
Go ahead and switch, yeah.
Great, so I'm in the
Google Cloud Console,
and when you log in, we provide
you a bunch of graphical tools
to help you understand.
So we're in the next Spanner.
So if you saw any of the Spanner
talks, you've seen the demo.
It's been running
over in the pavilion.
This is a globally replicated
Cloud Spanner instance.
So what this means is we have
data in the United States,
Europe, and Asia.
So Iowa, Oklahoma,
Belgium, and Taiwan.
We've got 50 nodes of capacity.
And so what this means is
we can do about 500,000
reads a second and about
100,000 writes a second.
So you get about 10,000 reads
and 2,000 writes per node.
You can see CP realization
and the type of data.
We've got about 17 terabytes
of data that we're running.
We provide you some
monitoring tools,
so you can see what we've been
doing over the last seven days.
Going back, you can see
we were loading some data,
running a bunch of demos.
You can see the
operational work-through.
You can see how much
data we've been writing,
and you can see that
we've been scaling up
to about 18 terabytes of data.
So we provide all these
tools as part of the product.
If we want to then go ahead
and look at a database--
so again, multiple databases
inside of a instance,
you can see here
all of our tables.
So we can look at
the account table.
We can see the schema.
We can see indexes.
So under event, we can
see we've got indexes.
If I want to preview
the data, I can.
So we're going to look
at the venue info table.
And if we want to
preview it, we can look
and say, OK, these are the
venue IDs, venue names,
and country codes.
If I want to introspect
my data and take a look,
I can go ahead
and write a query.
I'm going to cheat
and cut and paste
because I'm a terrible typer
when people are watching me.
It's the end of the Conference.
I really want to
be on the beach.
So let's look for any venues
that have beach in the title.
We run the query,
43 milliseconds
to query across 18
terabytes of data
in three continents in
five different regions.
And as one of my
colleagues likes to say,
what's so remarkable
about this query
is how unremarkable it is.
Select venue ID, venue name,
country code from venue
where venue name contains beach.
This is standard ANSI 2011 SQL.
There's nothing special
about this at all.
If I want to see how would
that query look like,
we provide a query explain.
So you can look at the
data and say, OK, we
did a distributed union.
We get down to the end, we
see, oh, there's a table scan.
That's probably bad.
I should probably add an
index for this type of query
and add a secondary index to
make these queries even faster.
So we can get that
43 milliseconds down
to 10 milliseconds.
Talked a little bit about
the developer experience.
So again, I'm a
Python developer.
So I'm in Cloud Shell.
So for those of
you who don't know,
if you click this little
button up here in the corner,
that actually spins up
a VM in your project
and instantiates a SSH
session into the VM, which
allows you to basically
have command line
access to all of your VMs.
So if I'm getting
ready to run this,
the first thing I'm
going to do is say, OK, I
need the client library.
So I apologize for using pseudo.
It's bad hygiene,
but this is a demo.
Google Cloud Spanner.
So I'm going to
check and make sure I
have all my dependencies.
Great, I've got them installed.
Let's go ahead and
start a command line,
interactive command line.
Great, so going back
and doing that code
that we did before, first
thing I'm going to do
is grab my import.
I'm going to import my package.
I'm going to grab my client.
So this client is created.
It's using credentials
based on the fact that I've
done G Cloud, so it
knows where to find
the credentials in my JSON
file with my credentials.
Great, I've got a
client, and I need
to grab a handle to my instance.
Got an instance.
Need a database.
Give me a handle on my database.
Obviously we could do this
all in one line of code.
And now I'm going
to run a query.
Great, so, again, what I've
done is I've selected venues.
We just did a talk in
Cloud Next in Tel Aviv.
So I wanted all the venues
that are in Jerusalem.
I can then print this
out and just say,
for row in results print row.
And these are the results.
So seven lines of
code, I've run a query
over 18 terabytes of data,
returned them and printed them
out to the command line.
That's all it takes to get
started on Cloud Spanner.
And we spent a
lot of time really
optimizing this to
make sure that it feels
idiomatic for Python and
idiomatic for all the client
libraries.
So it's very clean to use.
The last thing I'll show
you is that we actually
export all of our
data into Stackdriver.
So for those of
you who don't know,
Stackdriver is our multi
cloud monitoring system.
It provides logging
and monitoring.
You push metrics.
So we've pushed all
of these metrics
into Stackdriver, which allows
you to build custom dashboard.
So this is our
ticker sales demo.
So we can see Spanner
utilization over time,
throughput to the database.
Let's do a week.
We can see the number
of nodes we have,
the size of the demo database.
And because the data
is in Stackdriver,
you can set up custom alerts.
So custom alerting policies
that can either send you
emails, text messages,
integration with things
like pager duty,
whatever it happens to be
for your monitoring system.
Because all the data is
available in Stackdriver,
you can set up
whatever type of custom
alerting and monitoring
you want to do.
So Cloud Spanner really
from the beginning
was integrated with all the
various parts of Google Cloud
Platform to make it as easy and
seamless for people to get up
and running.
And so these are
just some examples,
along with things like
identity and access management
and the way that we do our
auto logging, so that all of it
just works out of the box.
[MUSIC PLAYING]